[Music]
here we go again Sony have accidentally
revealed the lineup for PS Plus
subscribers for the month of April 2020
and it's a whole week earlier than
planned perfect timing as we're all
stuck indoors do me a favor like and
subscribe if you enjoy these videos and
let's get right into this the first game
is uncharted 4 a thief's end made by the
same people who are currently working on
the Last of Us part 2 Uncharted 4 takes
the third-person action-adventure
escapades of treasure hunter and
explorer Nathan Drake as he's coked out
of retirement by his long-lost brother
Sam the usual over-the-top puzzle
solving is here stealth combat and
action movie set PCs filled the entire
game's length which is about 15 hours
for first-time players visually it's a
huge step up from previous entries and
the story stays compelling throughout
with one of the most fulfilling endings
to any saga I've seen and hey you can
play Crash Bandicoot 2 plus if you had
PS plus two months ago you already have
the first three installments in Drake's
adventure his entire story is now yours
to play reviews back in 2016 were
through the roof tens and 9.5 s
everywhere with the lowest score I could
find eight out of ten done that's good
if this is Drake's last hurrah it's a
good send-off get it played while you're
in isolation I'll go into the comments
and look for people complaining that
they already on it you do you the second
game is dirt rally 2.0 a racing
simulator that was released about a year
ago simulation is the key word here as
the in-game physics are paramount the
consistency of each terrain you cross
impacts your vehicle causing minut
handling changes you'll make when you're
driving in laymen terms
driving on tarmac is different than
driving in the rain on mud yeah I'm a
simple man we'll be racing all around
the globe with a mixture of real-world
tracks and remastered raceways from the
series with 50 cows to use including
rallycross supercars the campaign mode
has impressive depth and tactical
changes such as changing the compound of
your tires
Codemasters have attempted to make dirt
2.0 much more accessible to new players
so don't be put off with how intense it
may sound right now reviews I've been
hitting about 8.5 out of 10
whereas user scores on ps4 our 5.7
hmm this game is like chalk and cheese
the Marmite effect we call it you'll
have to decide for yourself think you'll
try it and if you're watching this
before March 27th stick around for a
second
on the 27th PS Plus subscribers will be
able to try predator hunting grounds a
whole month before it releases
completely free jump into this
asymmetric multiplayer as either a part
of a four-man military badass team or
the predator himself who will win team
work of a single hunter the trial lasts
one weekend and is free to PC players
too so that's April with PS Plus if
there's any changes to the release date
I'll pin it in the first comment below
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure stay safe and stay
awesome see ya
[Music]